Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and the Walking
Dead finale totally delivered on the wtf and
left things in such an unexpected cliffhanger
moment that we’re all forced to bookmark
season 5 episode 1 in our calendars.
A lot of the big things we expected went down
but there were a few surprises.
Mostly what that cliffhanger ended up being,
and the final body count at the end of the
episode.
Quick shoutout for my giveaway.
Since I just hit a hundred and fifty thousand
subscribers, I’m going to give away three
amazon gift cards to random subscribers in
the comments.
Just leave a comment on this video and I’ll
announce the winners in my Q&A video tomorrow.
So let’s wade right in to the blood with
top 5 moments and then a post mortem review.
Careful for spoilers if you haven’t seen
the episode yet.
Here we go, Number 5 - Hershel flashbacks.
If you had trouble pinpointing when these
scenes were happening, it was basically in
the time between the Season 3 finale and the
start of Season 4.
About two months after Woodbury.
I loved the Hershel and Patrick cameos, may
the rest in pieces.
The bigger theme of the episode was “Who
Am I?”
Carl even said it himself, “Who are We?”
I felt like they were foreshadowing Rick’s
line from the comics when he says “We Are
The Walking Dead”.
But it never came.
Maybe next season when we see the second half
of the cliffhanger.
Who else laughed when Patrick made the comment
about legos being for kids and they panned
over to Carl cleaning his gun like a pro.
Chandler Riggs has grown a lot since season
3 so he looked way different.
I’d bet they waited till recently to shoot
these scenes rather than shoot them at the
beginning of the season.
Did anyone else feel like it was almost Hershel’s
fault that Rick became ineffectual Farmer
Rick, the one Carl got so mad at for not being
the badass he was in this episode.
It was noble, I don’t blame him or anything,
but you could see how much Hershel was convincing
him to start living like a pacifist and less
like the monster Michonne and Carl talked
about later.
Number 4 - I’m Just Another Monster Too
Carl and Michonne’s talk was so brutal.
Especially when Michonne explained the rest
of her origin story with her son Andre and
Mike and Terry.
It was hard to tell whether she turned them
into pets to punish them or punish herself
for not being there to save them.
I really think she was punishing herself.
It was nice that she acknowledged the mechanics
of using walker pets as camouflage.
Carl really just explained what all the tension
between him and Rick has been about lately,
it’s really that Carl has felt like he’s
turning into a monster and isn’t the “legos
type” that Rick wants him to be.
This was really true for almost everyone in
the episode, am I a monster or am I a lego
fanboy/fangirl.
Feel free to let me know which one you are
in the comments.
Number 3 - Welcome to Terminus, to watch,
firefight
There are times when characters do crazy stupid
things and there are times when you feel so
proud for how careful they’re being.
I was proud of Rick for this entire episode,
you can clearly tell that he has learned from
past events and isn’t going to trust anyone
ever again.
Thus the backdoor entry.
I felt like that idea, you can’t trust anyone
was just hammered home when they passed through
that creepy shrine and it said “Never again,
Never Trust”.
As much as Terminus has been a mystery, I
don’t think that any of us thought these
were good people.
Even when we finally met Gareth.
He was just way too disarming, he’s totally
not the governor.
Scott Gimple and Robert Kirkman made a big
point of saying that there would be no Negan
or other big bad like them for a long time.
But Gareth does seem like the leader.
I can’t say it enough though, Rick was on
his shit in this episode.
Eyes of the hawk, no bullshit.
Where did you get that watch?!
Number 2 - The Survivors are Reunited in Traincar
A
The biggest surprise here was that everyone
is still okay, with all their limbs.
Asterisk, where the eff is Beth?
For now we can just say everyone is still
in the condition the entered in.
Let me know if you disagree, but can we all
just say what we’re thinking...cannibals.
I actually cheered when Rick slapped that
plate out of Carl’s hands.
Don’t eat the people meats.
You can never come back from that.
This isn’t an episode of Hannibal!
We won’t get confirmation till Season 5,
but I’m expecting them to tie everything
up in that first episode.
Which is only seven months away.
No big deal, we can all just write terminus
fan fiction until then.
No creepy cannibal sex stuff though.
Speaking of which...
my Number WTF moment 1 - Joe’s Group Are
the Marauders from the Comics
So it went down almost exactly how we expected.
If you’re not familiar with the comics,
in issue 57 the marauders were a couple of
people that sexually assaulted Carl and tried
to kill them and Rick bit a giant hunk out
of one of their necks and then brutally revenge
killed the one that assaulted Carl.
The one difference was that shot of Michonne
holding Carl.
It’s exactly like the panel in the comic,
except it was Abraham holding him.
Even though I thought this would happen it
was still hard to watch.
I liked the way they showed us that first
moment after, Rick in shock and then jumped
back to the beginning.
Did anyone else think it was strange that
Rick seemed so fazed in that moment, then
when Daryl sat down, he seemed totally fine.
Red beard full of blood.
I wanted to start calling him redbeard, like
he was a different character.
Because he feels so much more action oriented
and driven than he has in the last couple
of episodes.
He says the same thing Tyreese said to Carol
after the whole Lizzie WTF episode.
We do what we do because of them.
When Rick said it he was talking about Carl
specifically, Tyreese was talking about Judith.
So now it’s your turn to let it all out,
let me know what your biggest WTF moment was
in the comments.
Was it the Marauders or was it the cliffhanger?
I’ll be doing season 5 predictions tomorrow
in addition to my Q&A video, so we can talk
about the fate of Beth and the Terminus Cannibals.
Here’s a quick post mortem on the finale
and season 4 as a whole.
Let me stop my hands from shaking a little
bit.
Overall I give the finale and A just for character
development.
Of course I was disappointed that they left
so many big questions unanswered, where is
Beth when are they going to reveal all the
cannibalism, who is going to die next?
But that’s what a really good series does,
it demands that you continue watching.
So I will give them props for ending it on
such a high moment.
The thing that stuck out most was Rick, not
just because of his WTF moment with the Marauders,
but because he’s either reset to that person
right at the beginning of the flashbacks,
that Rick right after the Woodbury battle.
Or he’s more of a monster than ever.
So far he still seems like he has a grip on
reality and I was really satisfied with the
way he handled the Terminus situation.
There’s nothing they could have done.
It looked like they had at least 50 people
with rifles pointed at them.
And a leader, an archer a samurai and a kid
can only kill so many people at once.
Was anyone else bummed Gareth didn’t give
Carl a cool nickname too?
That last moment with Rick is a good preview
for what the survivors will be like in season
5.
No more bullshit, no more farming.
Just straight up ass kicking.
I know a lot of you guys commented on how
weak you thought this season was after all
the crazy action during season 3.
I mean, it’s hard to top a walker head aquarium.
That’s why I feel like season 4 had to be
this story where all the characters realized
that they can’t go back to being normal
people, never again.
They come first.
It sets them up in a nice dicotomy with the
creepy Terminus cult.
Let me know what your final thoughts are and
post all the questions you want me to include
in the Q&A and let me know what you want to
talk about most in my Season 5 predictions
video.
Like i said, i’ll try to post both of those
tomorrow.
Right now click here for the Q&A and click
here for the rest of my season 4 videos in
case you need to rewind for a sec.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!